joining me now is one of the stars of
good girls she
is uh on this program currently in
season four that airs sunday nights at
10 p.m eastern
on nbc she is christina hendricks how
are you christina hendricks
i'm well how are you i'm doing for
better for talking to you i just told
you before i hit record on the zoom i am
a fan so i don't care who knows it i
i want to share that um you know
honestly
and i'm sure you hear this quite a bit
that your work in mad men was
spectacular
and um i'm assuming you hear that quite
a bit despite the
the success of of good girls on nbc i
imagine that's what you get quite a bit
right it's nice i mean people are still
watching the show
i think people uh re-watched mad men
during the pandemic i think it was a big
you know a big one for people to go back
to right and so
um you know it's funny i've had i can't
show you i don't have it right here but
my
my logo of my show is me running in a
suit and tie and i've had jon hamm on
the show
he thought it was a very don draper sort
of
silhouetted look like falling out of a
building so
um i do appreciate you know the finer
things of what your show
was all about uh when did you first get
a script for that when did you first
have that
uh fall into your world christina
hendricks
it was um it was pilot season
and and for those who don't know what
pilot season is it's when all of us
actors rush out
trying desperately to get a job for that
season and it used to be that
you would sort of cast all the new shows
at once it's changed over the years now
there's different seasons and streaming
and all that so it's changed but it used
to be
if you don't get a job in this two
months you're not gonna
work for the next the rest of the year
so it's a lot of pressure at this time
uh of year and it was one of many
scripts
that got sent to the house and and uh
so many of the scripts that you read are
similar
you think oh there's that that medical
one there's that this
and this one stood out everyone was
talking about oh did you read this
period piece it's so interesting it's so
different it's so
smart and um so i just went and
auditioned
like like all my other auditions and
i just i think i just wanted it really
really badly well
um the pilot i remember blew me away
where again it's not really much for
spoiler alert because it's been out for
quite some time and people should see it
anyway but
you know where you see the character of
don draper sort of live the life of a
single man
in new york city and the life of uh
an advertising executive of that time
and
then he goes home to his wife and that
was the end of the first episode and i
sat there i'm like okay this show is
quite different and i'm wondering if you
had a similar reaction
and whether your character at the time
you you knew the direction
that your character was going to go or
allow you as an actress to go in
with your character at the time i didn't
i didn't know much at the time and and
matt will be the first to say that the
joan character was supposed to just
be a recurring character that would show
up every once in a while and sort of
help describe exposition in the show and
just help sort of
move the story along and and um
he liked what i did and and he liked the
joan and peggy character together and
he started to see something with the
dynamic of those two characters that led
it to be
a much more important role in the show
thankfully and um
you know at the time i i only i think
joan was in maybe three scenes in the
pilot
that's it it was me just trying to piece
together who this person was like okay
she's
she seems kind of bossy she seems kind
of in control she's clearly
had sex with a couple men in the office
like trying to sort of
get any little bit of information i
could
and turn that into something um and uh
then
and i do remember matt weiner the
creator of the show he said early on
um you're gonna get lots of stuff with
uh roger sterling
i was like yes because that's the one
guy i know on the show and he's really
good
because none of us knew each other you
know so you knew john slattery going in
i didn't know him as a person that i was
okay
okay yeah because that to me his
character
was like um cotton candy every time he
showed up like
the scene was that much better when his
character
showed up on it because he was laugh out
loud funny and then the way you all guys
all played together
was phenomenal i i just loved everything
about
his character it's interesting that you
were drawn as well too yeah
well john does such a one thing that
john does that i love
so much is that so many times you could
watch a show
and and a character will say something
funny
and you know it's because the writer
wrote something really funny right
but john always played it that he knew
roger knew it was funny
right it was like roger has a really
great sense of humor roger tells these
great jokes obviously matt weiner you
know in an office somewhere writing
these very clever things
but john always played it that it was so
personal and that he
he was cracking himself up and i think
that was so charming
i have christina hendricks here on the
rich eisen show i met john slattery on a
plane once
and i'm uh outside of what i'm doing
right here the host of nfl network and
he was a giants fan and he was
kind of we we kind of hit it off on the
flight do you have any
sports uh team or did you grow up
anywhere where you were following sports
play sports in any way shape or form
christina do you have any connections
new york city ballet accounts
yes i can imagine that was a very
competitive and
i imagine it was a very competitive
cutthroat winning environment i imagine
i i i don't know a lot about sports i
didn't grow up in a sports
family i grew up with um sci-fi
nerds as a brother and a dad um so i
grew up on cosmos and star trek
so you know a different way so you knew
more about carl sagan than carl lewis is
basically what you're saying exactly
right
star trek so what's your favorite star
trek episode then what's your what's
your favorite one of those do you
remember that or no
uh i don't i don't remember i always i
remember
always enjoying when they went to a
planet when they got off
they ship and it was like some sad paper
mache rock
you know and it was i was always like oh
thank god they're off that [ __ ] love
that
so you you that's the way you grew up
fantastic
so tell me about uh good girls what are
you what you what attracted you to this
project
uh christina you know a big decision to
to choose a new series to go on to after
mad men i took you know a break and did
some films and and did guest spots on
other things but
i wanted to make sure i was really
really intrigued by something before i
signed on to what could be you know
quite some time and
i just loved that it was drama and
comedy at the same time and that it was
weird and quirky and what seemed like
real kind of dialogue between people and
it just felt very modern and fresh
and i thought i could do this for a
while i think i could contribute
something here well season four
so you have been doing it for a while i
mean that it's kind of it's kind of a
it's kind of rare to to have now two
shows that have uh
a nice run in this day and age certainly
when there's so many different things
that you can watch that's pretty cool
there's
so much content out there and so much
good stuff
um and i do think we found our place in
the world
you know in our in our quirky groovy
little spot and yeah
uh before mad men i was on series that
only went one season so this is
you're on a roll you're on a roll
basically is what you're saying you're
on a roll
well uh before i let you go on my show
we have something called celebrity true
or false where i have some facts that
are
out there on your uh wikipedia imdb
pages and things like that that i need
you to
if you don't mind confirm as to whether
true or false yes clarify
all right so you're celebrity true or
false with christina hendricks you tell
me if this is true
or false for the academy award-winning
movie american beauty
your hand appears in the movie poster
holding the rose is that true or false
true what's the deal behind that then
i used to be a model and one of the gigs
i got
was to go and shoot a movie poster had
no idea what the film was and there were
two models myself and one other and we
did different versions of her hand and
her stomach and my stomach and her hand
and my hand in both
and my hand made it in and her stomach
made it in so
you're that was it your your your hand
was
were you a hand model as well other than
just or just what i mean
i did a few gigs where i did some hand
modeling i was a ballet dancer so i
guess i know how to move my hands in
another
fashion right um it was just
a plain old gig i probably got paid 100
bucks or something i was just able to
have a job
didn't know what american beauty was
going to be and then finally saw and i
was like
hey that's my hands so you're just
you know you see on in trains and uh on
the sides of buses and
and uh bus stops i thought very little
about it for a very long time and then
at one point i said something to my
brother and
and he goes oh yeah my sister's hands
american beauty and everyone was like
wait
what you just never dropped that i was
like it was just one of my games i got
to go very good you you have to own that
and i'm glad that that's that's actually
true because that's
wild um next one you have five
soundtrack credits on imdb
including the 65th annual tony awards
when you perform side by side is that a
is that a true credit for you
as well yes okay so
i mean that must be uh
like one of your favorite credits i must
imagine is that you get to perform
something like that as opposed to other
things
and that includes hand modeling for
academy award posters but right
it was when i mean i grew up doing
musical theater in a small town and i
grew up studying ballet
and so to do a sondheim show
at lincoln center and then get to
perform at the tony's
i mean i'm getting chills just thinking
about it it's probably one of my
proudest moments okay uh is it true that
on the set of mad men
the cast did drink alcohol but the
cigarettes were not real
is that true no no
there was uh caramel colored water or
vodka water okay um i'm sure
i can i can confirm that we shared beers
at the end of the day sometimes
okay so the the there was never any sort
of real actual
on-screen throwing one back that never
actually happened
no we have to memorize lines and act and
do all sorts of things
and the cigarettes by california law
have to be an herbal
cigarette so they are also not but they
are still disgusting
and we had to smoke five billion of them
yeah ham said it tasted like a mixture
of smoking pot and soap
is what he said that
that seems like a high praise
it was that bad it was that it was
literally that bad
well here you know you you also got to
remember sometimes on a monday morning
we would be on set
6 a.m right you would rehearse and then
there would be a
sea of secretaries and advertising guys
and they'd be like all right
rolling and everyone would take out
their fake cigarette and light it and it
just at 6am with the smell
filling the air in everyone's mouth
filled with that
yeah very unpleasant and last one for
you the scripts for mad men were
followed verbatim
no improvisation and any changes had to
be discussed with matthew weiner first
said is that true that is true
never once huh you had to hit it nailed
it certainly didn't come at him
my i i remember one day i think matt was
directing the episode
and there was just a scene where uh john
slattery walked through the room
had to do a bit of a walk and talk and
walk towards me and i was in
the background having a conversation
with another employee
and matt said just say like some office
business stuff
i think we tried two different lines and
he was like no no no don't do that
please don't do that so even our
background um
ad-libs didn't make it in damn okay well
look it all worked out and i i just
think it's really
it's really neat to you know have met
you and to find out that
you know you have a similarity to your
character and the fact that you made
something of your opportunity that it
was supposed to just be sort of like a
uh a character here and there and she
became such an integral
phenomenal uh character in in the show
that earned you
multiple emmy nominations so
congratulations on that and also on good
girls
thank you so much it was really nice to
meet you right back at you anytime you
want to come and promote anything we'll
we'll talk star trek or whatever you
want cosmos
i'll do a little sports research okay
there you go well you know
you can have sports true or false and
i'll tell you what's true or not you
know
christina hendricks right here on the
rich eisen show check out new episodes
of good girls sunday nights
at 10 p.m eastern on nbc
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here